hello reject nation its Greg Alba here
and I'm John Paul Rudd's having a good
day today people yup as ant-man trailer
dropped and now the mute trailer has
dropped which he's not the main star of
but I know he's in it because the early
images of it shown pictures of
specifically Paul Rudd and his awesome
stache
they CG down Alexander Skarsgard plays a
mute this is the like what are those
called it's not the direct sequel
spirituals yeah yeah it's like a
spiritual sequel Oh to you a moon I
believe has a Blade Runner aesthetic
that's really in right now with Blade
Runner 2049 altered to carbon and now
mute and now that we can finally realize
those crazy even bigger technology at
hey shout out today for patron efika
Makunga
[Music]
[Music]
nice
I want to know what the deal is with
this crazy bartender this kind of thing
it's my reputation he's gotta go oh
[Laughter]
he drops me taking me to the [ __ ] off
[Music]
Wow
you're gonna give me some my big boy are
you gonna channel that famous Amish
[Laughter]
[Music]
right now made a secret anymore
you do
so your soul
[Music]
Wow Bladerunner 2052 looks really [ __ ]
isn't here first off I'm happy for
Duncan Jones because this was part of
his passion projects that he was able to
get off the ground and especially after
following the lackluster response of
Warcraft yeah good for him to go back to
something that is more along the lines
of what he's truly passionate about
everyone loved moon I even like source
code a lot the people like so I'm happy
to see you the more just happy for
Duncan Jones to be doing this this movie
has a lot going for right now with
Alexander Skarsgard winning the Golden
Globe and all the other awards for big
little lies Paul Rudd hot Justin Theroux
yeah yeah just the throw can really
disguise himself pretty well a lot of
the time actually so yeah there's like a
lot of big actors in here the director
is really cool and he co-wrote the
script too so I feel there's a lot of
great things already going for it that
I've already gotten me intrigued into
seeing this prior to even seeing the
trailer I'm looking forward to it the
Blade Runner aesthetic is beginning to
get a little tiresome to me you know cuz
you got ghost in the shell' last year
Blade Runner 2049 the altered carbon
look and now this it's weird it's
projecting the future Emily I guess
that's probably what it would look like
regardless but at the same time yeah I'm
back and forth because part of me really
is excited about the influx of sci-fi
yeah that we're still getting I'm glad
that the flops like ghost in the shell'
and things like that didn't ruin our
chances like this but at the same time
yeah I've seen this aesthetic beyond
that I feel like with what has to offer
unique that I really caught on to was
the personalities of the characters
because these guys aren't like
high-level hunters or whatever you know
yeah they're not following like bounties
of any type you're following a mute his
performance feels like it's gonna be
resembling of something like Ryan
and drive even though he's not mute in
driving silent guy on a mission so you
got that character who's just a
bartender and then you got this surgeon
and Justin throw his buddy
but they kind of feel like they're out
of the big lebowski in a way I don't
know maybe because it's holing but their
personality and their advantage that
personality in dialog specifically is
what is making this feel more unique
because you're focusing more on just
human beings yeah quirky characters and
it seems like the actors are being
allowed to bring their personalities to
it in a way that feels a little more
down to the yeah round a little more
lived-in then you're you know heavy sigh
yeah feels like it'll still be a
personal tale in this giant setting yeah
I always appreciate when sci-fi movies
like these managed to bring esoteric
characters that feel kind of quirky and
life like yeah yeah yeah I like the you
know Paul Rudd and just throw they both
have broad backgrounds but they also do
a lot of comedy and a lot of improv
bases yeah ohhara was having me laugh at
the truth ya know seeing the combination
of the cast and you know Duncan Jones
directing is is pretty fascinating to me
I'm excited about this yeah this looks
like a cool movie it didn't seem like it
was all about the cool you know action
visuals it feels like it'll be a
character piece and a mood piece too and
as you know like Blade Runner it seems
like Netflix is following that model
again of giving their creative their
control and stuff and especially after
something like Warcraft I have to
imagine that for Duncan Jones it's
probably nice to get back to something
that's a little more in your hand you
know in your wheelhouse yeah control
stuff like that so this is kind of a
chance I imagine to redeem yeah after
that all right well hey Paige from the
day shout out for a fika makanga how's
it gonna freakin with hunger I wanted to
give you a shout out on this video
because you are treating me like a mute
I get one message back from this guy on
patreon saying where are you from buddy
he's like I'm from South Africa that's
all he said I even sent him like a list
of questions to try to like incorporate
something specific for your shout out
and you haven't gotten back to me for
some reason dude why is that why is that
is it because I
slept with Charlize Theron and she never
got a phone call from me is it because I
slept with Dave Matthews is it because I
took a dump on Neill Blomkamp
is it because I didn't list also Coakley
is one of my favorite actors which he is
what is it man because now all I got to
go off are South Africa thing and I
can't do a South African accent John and
I tried looking up how to do a South
African accent alright I couldn't even
do the words I just got a watch and you
know by every dance for now and watch
Blood Diamond and then we're solid and
all honestly thanks for being a part of
our patreon we appreciate any support we
have and it's cool to know that some
from South Africa watches our Channel we
have a lot of northern African
subscribers but not you're like the only
South African subscriber yet accurate
it's 100 percent accurate check our
analytics we'll send them to you why not
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified every time one of our
videos is up check out our patreon now
you can become a patron oject today
there's a lot of videos on their full TV
show reactions full music video
reactions and weekly Q&A s last but not
least download and follow us in the
Stardust app Pais